Father you're here
well let's dig in oh my god i mean you isn't this
great is it the most dysfunctional family ever
you are a terrible father respectfully you're some
kind of police assistant consultant so where's
your desk he has a desk maybe if you work hard
enough you might one day rise to this man's level
i think it's time that you and i worked on our
relationship so that i may have a relationship i
cannot fix you lucifer i think it's time time for
me to retire i now know exactly what i need to do
i'm going to be god i'm going
to do things differently
i'm trying to wrap my mind around what all
of this means for us what could go wrong
michael's been gathering support from
the others michael wants to be god
we are going to war it looks like
he has a good shot want a drink
i should have known we'd smell something
fishy aw dad joke nice thanks i'm practicing
the darker the darkness the brighter the light
what's the point i've already won
lucifer's come a long way he does his
best when you put a little faith in him
why are you doing this if i ever said
those three words to you it would be a lie
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new lucifer season 5 part 2 trailer they just
broke the season in half so this is the rest of
the episodes and god has just shown up so we'll
break it all down there's a bunch of easter eggs
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos dennis haysberg
showing up as god he definitely does sound like
he has the voice of god doing all those tv ads
there's a very chuck supernatural spin to this
too where he basically says i think it's time for
me to retire so lucifer obviously gets the bright
idea i'm going to be the new god in the trailer
is basically hyping up a big battle between him
and michael with michael trying to rally support
from the other archangels in the rest of heaven
so that he can take over they kind of seeded
that storyline in the background during the
first half of season five with the idea that
they were taking the supernatural route with
god where god himself wasn't around so much so
you have the other angels that are left over
the other archangels like michael for instance
that are left to cause trouble to try and take
control of heaven themselves until god steps in
himself literal and metaphorical deus ex machina
that's basically what happened at the end of
season 5 episode eight where they're basically
in this all-out three-way battle with amenities
michael and lucifer unfurling their wings as he
appears but because this is lucifer and they treat
this like a really dysfunctional family like the
most dysfunctional family in the history of
creation so they actually play it like he's
going to be around in a couple of episodes at
least being this sort of weird father figure to
lucifer like when you have childhood sports games
or music performances or events at your school
and an absentee father shows up and it's just
really awkward because he's never around and he
doesn't really know how to be a father at least
in the way that you want him to be so they really
play up the comedy of him just walking around the
police station just trying to understand what it
is that lucifer's been doing this whole time even
though the whole idea is that god is supposed to
be omnipotent all-knowing and so he should know
the answers to all these questions so i do wonder
if there's going to be a funny twist behind this
like he does seem very inquisitive here like he's
waiting for other people to explain things to
him when really that shouldn't be necessary
usually you only do that when you want to humor
someone so maybe that's what god is doing in all
these scenes when he's walking around asking
questions of them like please explain it to me
as if i'm not the most powerful all-knowing being
in all of creation they also reveal the titles of
all the rest of the eight episodes they're eight
episodes from the second half of season five so
it starts with family dinner so obviously that's
the dinner that they're having at the table here
very biblical scene that they're having here
episode 10 is titled resting devil face which is
just a reference to resting [ __ ] face episode 11
is titled bloody celestial karaoke jam episode 12
is titled dan espinoza naked and afraid episode
13 is a little harmless stalking episode 14
is nothing lasts forever episode 15 is called is
this really how it's going to end and then episode
16 the finale is called a chance at a happy ending
so lucifer kind of talks to god about this during
the trailer where he's like we need to work on our
relationship so i can have a chance at having a
relationship with chloe is who he's speaking of he
didn't say chloe's name but he says a relationship
they kind of play with that back and forth during
the trailer too when he's talking to chloe like
they have that big song and dance number on the
football field which is also where you see them
have this big angel standoff like they turn it
into a metaphorical and a literal battlefield
but they do have a full-blown musical number it
sounds like during that episode i think the idea
is they wanted to go full-blown musical at some
point just because he spent so much time singing
during the series it is kind of weird to see
chloe calling god out like you are a terrible dad
respectfully of course respectfully and obviously
the hilarious idea that he thinks of dan is this
really high figure like maybe if you work hard
enough someday you'll be as good as this man here
and of course because therapy is so much of
a trope of the series they pull god in for a
family therapy session with him i don't know how
close this is going to wind up feeling to the
supernatural overarching storyline with the way
they weave god into their show the chuck character
because even though in earlier seasons it seemed
like he was just completely checking out like you
know what i think i'm gonna go for a little walk
about i'm gone i'm not gonna be around for a long
time or he hinted at the idea that he was going to
permanently retire in one of the other archangels
or somebody was going to have to replace him as
the leader of heaven he always winds up coming
back so i would be surprised if dennis haysberg's
god character genuinely does want to actually
retire and does fully wind up leaving the universe
like they're playing up this whole idea that
lucifer is getting really high on himself with the
idea that he could potentially be the new god and
completely rewrite the rules of heaven like i'm
gonna make it way better than it was before i'm
gonna do things my way and on the other side of
things you have michael who's being positioned as
this antagonist like somehow he's even worse than
lucifer who is the devil and is supposed to be the
worst person here but he's more of an anti-hero
during the series so how do you make him feel like
a hero you make michael feel even more despicable
like somehow him being in charge of heaven being
the new god would be terrible for everyone you
see the metaphor that they're going for with them
wearing all this creepy armor on the battlefield
here on this football field but even if you're not
a scholar of the bible or stories about lucifer
or anything like that there's this quote from god
where he says the darker the darkness the brighter
the light the whole idea of lucifer is that his
name means lightbringer lucifer lightbringer so
the idea like they contrast this devil face like
he's judging someone with his devil face as god
is watching this happen like oh so this is what
it looks like without saying it in so many words
god is basically telling him that he is his choice
to succeed him potentially as god but i think the
whole idea is this is meant to be some grand test
because usually in any series like this or
supernatural for instance where you have god
entering the story as an actual character usually
he winds up just messing with people testing them
to see if they'll choose the right path just to
see what will happen so i would be very surprised
if lucifer himself actually does wind up being
god because the show was renewed for season six
so they actually do have to escalate things even
more than lucifer potentially battling for the
throne of heaven and i think the whole idea here
is that he actually really just wants a life with
chloe so he doesn't really want to be stuck in
hell but i think he'll also probably find that
he doesn't want to be stuck in heaven either like
that was kind of the plot at the end of season 4
where he went back to hell because he thought that
that was the only way to keep everyone safe and if
he didn't do that then things were going to erupt
in chaos then at the beginning of season five the
show finds another reason for him to come back to
planet earth because the big trope of the show is
sort of this police procedural with them having
adventures in each episode going to different
cases so presumably the same dynamic would exist
during season six so i think they're going to
continue to tease the idea of him potentially
becoming the next god but they'll have to come
up with some reason for him to come back to
planet earth and do more of this day-to-day
with chloe in the other team for the episodes and
it just doesn't feel like he could actually be god
and do this day-to-day stuff with the team
at the same time usually what happens with
situations like this in big stories where people
are battling for a throne like you talk about game
of thrones people battling for the iron throne
is that usually they have to wind up giving up
everything that they actually want and it doesn't
feel like lucifer would do that like he basically
had to choose between the throne of heaven and
chloe so it just doesn't feel like the show is
heading in that direction like it feels like they
want to go for a more optimistic ending so at some
point they'll have to explain how he does not
wind up being god so that he can stay on earth
doing this with chloe that's part of the whole
twist of his powers and the way they work around
chloe the way she nullifies his abilities so that
he can have a shot at a normal life with her like
actually live as a human with her but the other
big news you guys may have heard about is that
they're doing a justice league dark hbo series
with constantine and a bunch of the other core
justice league dark characters from the comics
but the thing is it's going to be on hbo max
lucifer is on netflix so i know a lot of people
are wondering which version of constantine they're
going to go with it sounds like they're going
to be casting someone new because you have this
whole crisis on infinite earth's crossover that
sort of binds the entire dc multiverse together
you have ezra miller's flash tying the justice
league snyder cut stuff the movie stuff to the
arrowverse tv stuff but i do believe netflix has
been pitching lucifer season six as the final
season of the show so if tom ellis continues
to play the character after this it would be
people using him in other productions the way they
explain it during crisis on infinite earth is the
universe that this version of lucifer is from is
earth 666 the only problem that i had with that is
the idea that god is supposed to be omnipotent in
the multiverse like it's supposed to be obviously
infinite universes but only one god one pantheon
of angels so theoretically there should only be
one lucifer in the entire multiverse they even
had a watchman easter egg on his earth too and
i think that was around the time that watchman
hbo was getting ready to spin up but i think
it was more of a reference to the watchmen comic
book but everyone let me know in the comments when
they eventually do get up to doing their justice
league dark hbo series do you actually want to see
matt ryan's constantine come back and cross over
do you want to see tom ellis's lucifer crossover
onto that the way they're explaining things at
warner brothers right now is that when it comes to
characters showing up in other people's movies
other people's tv shows they're just kind of
leaving it to each production each director to
do what they want to do or each writer to do what
they want to do with the characters so if they
want to bring in matt ryan or tom ellis versions
of the characters they can totally do that the
flash movie with ezra miller with michael keaton's
version of batman and ben affleck's batman
is supposed to clarify a little bit about how
they're handling the multiverse at least on the
movie side of things but post all your theories
in the comments below all the lucifer episodes
will hit netflix may 28th though and it sounds
like season six won't premiere obviously till next
year at some point but i don't know how they're
gonna break the episodes up they might do it half
and half like they did during season five while
you wait for everything click here for my full
falcon and winter soldier episode 6 finale video
and click here for that brand new thor 4 love and
thunder first look video learn all about russell
crowe's character thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!